the analysis now from our sports
correspondent Martha Kellner who joins
us Martha what's your take on these
breaking news lines from the Premier
League yeah I think it's a really
significant move on the Premier League
they wonder pressure to make some
commitment around player wages given
that we had yesterday the health
secretary Matt Hancock publicly saying
in that government press conference that
Premier League players had a duty to
accept to cut in wages and it really was
a very meaningful thing Premier League
they said as you were mentioning there
and that there's this 125 million pound
Relief Fund for the AFL and the National
League clubs those are the clubs which
are likely to find themselves in a
really deep crisis with the coronavirus
the clubs that relied on that matchday
income more than perhaps the Premier
League clubs and the Premier League have
also committed 20 million pounds to the
NHS which will be available immediately
in a charitable donation with regards to
players wages and there's been a
collective agreement between the 20
Premier League clubs that they'll
consult their players about what
effectively will be a 30% reduction in
wages whether that be through wage cuts
or deferred wages and so that's to do
with the financial side of things the
other major issue that was the
discussion in this conference call today
was when the Premier League will be
allowed to resume they had set their
sights on the season restarting at the
beginning of May and but there's an
agreement among them that that's simply
not going to be possible so that's going
to be kept under constant review
separate to this Premier League meeting
there was also a teleconference call
this more
and by the trade by the liveable acting
Jordan Henderson
but including all of the other 20
Premier League captains in which they
discussed what they as Premier League
players under the the heavy weight of
criticism that they are at the moment
having not collectively committed
anything what they could do to help with
this Relief Fund and my understanding is
that they've agreed that at some point
as a group any league players there will
be a one-off lump sum donation made he's
thought that that could run into many
millions of pounds and and it really is
about these players now get him back on
the front but and I'm told that these
discussions between the players about
giving this donation had been a thought
long before Matt Hancock made those
critical comments a long before the
public opinion team seemed to have
turned against them so the Premier
League clubs and the players are really
looking and to take a stand here